[Music]
[Applause]
we bring in reese Davis the host of
college game day you know if you had an
all hands team you know on kickoffs in
the onside kick
um but if you had an all hair team at
ESPN
Reese Davis Reese Davis would be uh
maybe the captain of that right now who
else would be on the all hair team at
ESPN race
oh you know what I tell you what Steve
Levy still has a pretty magnificent
quaffier it's uh you know thick and
Luscious I'm sure he'd be up there yeah
um
Gandhi's not bad uh Fowler you
yeah yeah Fowler Fowler's hair is pretty
good you you've got a pretty good quaff
you're working on your own there too
yeah I'm a I'm Emeritus or a Heritage is
uh is what I would I I would be and I
feel bad for Van Peezy I mean he had a
little bit of moss when he first got
there but uh best bald guy at the
mothership maybe it's van Peezy uh no
question about that he uh among hosts
for sure he's leading the way there
billis would tell you that he's easily
the best bald guy in terms of
adolescence yeah and don't rule out
vital
that's true uh he he might be bald guy
Americans too he's been bald a really
long time uh what's the coolest thing in
your office
well there are a couple of things here
obviously the personal stuff with you
know from my son's baseball career my
favorites but the Mark May Jersey who it
was my really first long-term college
football partner there I've got a billis
Jersey
on the side and I've also got a Desmond
Howard jersey nice over there so those
are the those are the things I like
secondary to the uh pictures of my kids
and stuff like that it's kind of awkward
to bring this up then
um
you know Kirk Herbstreit Jersey in your
office there you you know what Dan
the one thing about this is that these
guys Mark Desmond J were gracious enough
to give me the Jersey I I've mentioned
it to Herb Street and I've mentioned it
to Pollock and I've seen nothing from
herb Street he won't give me one and
Pollock says to me well I'll sign one
for you if you buy it I'm like are you
crazy I'm not doing that so so you know
I mean I'll put it up if they've got
I've got a I've also got another one
that downstairs that uh I've got a
Hubert Davis Jersey from North Carolina
that uh that he gave me Hubert and I
really close from working so that's a
prized possession as well all right your
initial reaction when the uh top four
came out
um I thought I was I was uh I didn't
have a problem with it personally I
would still have Tennessee four ahead of
TCU but it's you're splitting hairs I
mean both teams are really good both are
deserving of being in the top four you
know I I think the thing people have
noticed the most if you go a little bit
farther down and start looking ahead to
what could happen is USC being ahead of
UCLA but you know by a couple spots but
a few spots all that's going to work
itself out I didn't have a a big issue
with anything really the first two weeks
uh that they've done I thought they were
right to put Tennessee number one prior
to the Georgia game and I think that you
know it was reasonable to have them at
five behind TCU but personally I would
have had Tennessee four felt like TCU
was a courtesy this week a little bit I
think maybe that there have been some
backlash and not to say and I don't say
that in a way Dan I'm not one of the
guys who bashes the committee all the
time but sometimes when you do get some
public backlash about where team has
been ranked or whatever maybe it forces
you to reevaluate a little bit and
that's reasonable as long as you're not
doing it and making a different decision
simply because of that because nothing
really changed TCU did the same thing
they've done almost every week they fall
behind they turn on that powerful
offense they win the game and but this
time they got the benefit of the doubt
and I thought one of the questions you
know that I asked Sonny Dykes last night
it'll be a question for boo Corrigan
going forward
should it be necessary for TCU to be
undefeated as the Big 12 champion
because the Big 12 is is good and
balanced and deep and TCU easily could
be a one loss Big 12 champion and still
be worthy of consideration for the
playoffs yeah trying to figure this out
with uh some of these teams on the
periphery uh USC is a couple points away
from being undefeated where would they
be if they were undefeated would they be
a top four team because you bring in
pedigree
but I don't know if you would bring in
pedigree but I think they're powerful
they would be in a similar situation to
TCU Dan because their offense has been
terrific in their defense hasn't been as
good one could probably argue that many
respects tcu's defense has probably been
a little bit better than sc's and SC has
found a way to win on a couple of
occasions they've let a lot of teams
stay in the game for a long time if
they've been able to you know stop that
dew point conversion or stop Utah from
scoring late they probably they probably
would be around four or five I would
think but they they have some they have
some faults on their squad too they have
some warts as many of the teams do this
year probably probably warts uh for
everybody not named Georgian and maybe
Ohio State could you see Ohio State and
Michigan both getting into the final
four what what would this scenario be
where you could see the two Big Ten
teams uh to me I think that is every bit
as valid a question as the SEC and I
think what it would take week is a
Michigan win and that's not to say that
I think necessarily the Ohio state is
you know worlds better but Michigan's
non-conference schedule uh through some
fault of their own but some of it UCLA I
think have backed out of a contract a
couple years ago or something originally
they were supposed to play UCLA but the
all you could do is evaluate what they
did in their non-conference schedule is
not good their best non-conference
opponent was UConn so I think that would
hurt Michigan if it lost but if Michigan
went to Columbus and won obviously they
would be in and if it were a great game
and Ohio State lost in overtime lost on
a field goal or something like that but
still clearly looked like one of the
four best teams I think that would be
the scenario and I don't think it's
terribly far-fetched I think it's
something that should be evaluated and
and considered by all of us watching and
certainly by the committee just as much
as we will consider a one-loss non-sec
champion Tennessee team which will
likely be the case at the end of the
season talking to Reese Davis uh he's
the host of college game day they will
be in Austin Texas game day starts at 9
A.M they go till noon and you can watch
on ESPN ESPNU throughout the season
give me the team that's sort of hanging
around that maybe we're not talking
about that they could slip in there uh
come December
I think we're talking about most of them
but you probably hit it with USC uh
Oregon would be an interesting case
study because I've always been one that
if you have a behemoth loss as Oregon
did losing by 46 a few years ago Penn
State had a 39 Point loss and didn't get
in Ohio state had a 31 Point loss didn't
get in and I've sort of felt like that
was the right course of action
um because if you are capable of getting
beaten down like that if you have such a
small tournament in just four teams and
every little thing's got to count and
getting your doors blown off should
count so but I do think that there is a
scenario under which Oregon uh could
make it make it an interesting debate
and maybe could get in there on
selection day and I think that the same
could be true for USC and of course if
LSU is a two loss SEC Champion I sort of
feel like they have a ceiling on them
because they got their doors blown off
by Tennessee at home
I'd be hard-pressed to find a scenario
in which I would favor LSU over
Tennessee so you know it's LSU though
LSU Oregon and SC and maybe UCLA uh who
probably is a little bit undervalued by
the committee right now would be the
teams that aren't getting as much
attention that that could wind up there
the Heisman Trophy race reminds me of
when Mark Ingram won it was like we got
to give it to somebody uh Mark here you
go here's the Heisman because I don't
know if anybody is really distinguished
themselves Hendon hooker had it you win
that game and you're the front runner
clear front runner uh CJ Stroud didn't
look good against Northwestern uh where
are we going with this uh for the
Heisman that it really changed you're
100 right it really changed for Hendon
uh on Saturday because he's not going to
have that type of stage to win it late
uh like Bryce young did uh last year
like Mark Ingram did uh with the game
against Florida in the SEC Championship
game that year CJ Stroud is going to
have that platform uh when they play
Michigan late so I would say that he is
probably the favorite uh the guy who
probably ought to get a little more
attention for it just doesn't have the
numbers to back it up and it needs to be
both moments and numbers and that's
Stetson Bennett
um you know all that guy does is win and
make big big plays in their in their
biggest games he's sort of the heartbeat
of that team but he's only got 11
touchdown passes so some of it has to be
production so I would say CJ Stroud and
if you are looking for someone on the
outside it would probably be TCU
quarterback Max Duggan if you know if
they were to run the table if they beat
Texas you know I mean maybe he maybe
he's the one I would favor Stroud by a
pretty good margin over Max in terms of
handicapping the race but you know if
something odd happens and the other guy
Dan on the big stage might be a Blake
Quorum you know at Michigan if Michigan
were to win that game and Quorum goes
for two bills or something you know
maybe he could be the guy
safe travels to Austin thanks for
joining us as always Reese thanks Deb
that's Reese Davis popular host of
ESPN's college game day going to Austin
Texas and the Longhorns are favored by
seven
yes seven seven against TCU all right
got my attention on that one there